una recta secante se intersecta con la
curva igual al concepto de x en dos
puntos cuyas coordenadas en la variable
x son cero y te escribe una expresión de
m como función de ti que te dé la
pendiente de la recta secante y bueno en
esta ocasión lo que queremos hacer es
encontrar la pendiente de la recta
secante entre dos puntos cuyas
coordenadas x son cero ítem y bueno si
sé cuáles son sus coordenadas x puedo
encontrar cuál va a ser su valor en fx
porque hill tengo tengo la curva james
igual a coseno de t
así que qué te parece si hacemos una
tabla por aquí voy a poner a x ya fx
déjame hacer mi pequeña tabla por aquí
ok voy a poner por aquí am x
y por aquí voy a poner a fx
efe x igual ayer ok y bueno voy a tomar
estos dos valores x igual a 0 y x igual
a t
ahora cuando x vale 0 entonces me queda
el seno de bueno el coseno de cero ahora
sabemos cuánto vale el concepto de cero
el co seno de cero es lo mismo que uno
así que me quedan
el punto 0.1 y cuando x pallete bueno
tengo que ft es el coseno de tema
lo voy a escribir así bien ahora observa
tengo dos puntos que están en esta recta
secante que a su vez intersec a a
nuestra función dos veces entonces vamos
a poder encontrar cuánto valen aquí
puedo encontrar el cambio en game y de
igual manera puede ver cuánto es el
cambio en
el cambio en x y por lo tanto ahora sí
puedo decir que mi pendiente y pendiente
va a ser igual al cambio en que entre el
cambio en x ok y esto va a ser igual y
bueno si me tomo a éste como el punto
final vamos a tomarnos al segundo como
el punto final entonces el cambio en
quién va a ser la diferencia de estos
dos me quedaría el coce no el coseno de
a esto le quito 1 ok ya esto lo vamos a
dividir entre la diferencia de estos dos
si este es mi punto final me quedaría en
menos 0
-0 ahora de -0 es simplemente tm así que
aquí abajo me quedaría simplemente tm y
observa que en este caso tenemos escrita
a nuestra pendiente como función de t
que es justo lo que queríamos queremos
la pendiente como función de t y esto de
aquí ya no se puede simplificar porque
tenemos acá arriba al coste no de tema
por lo tanto esa base de nuestra
respuesta correcta nuestra respuesta va
a ser él
12 no dt menos uno está dividido a su
vez entre
y ya está con estos dos puntos fuimos
capaces de encontrar la pendiente como
función de t